>> Bret: BREAKING TONIGHT, THE
U.S. MILITARY IS RESPONDING
RIGHT NOW, IT’S UNDERWAY TO
YESTERDAY’S ROCKET ATTACK IN
IRAQ THAT LEFT TWO TO U.S.
PERSONNEL DAN.
THIS IS HAPPENING AT THIS HOUR.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN IS AT THE
PENTAGON WITH THE VERY LATEST.
>> U.S. MILITARY SOURCES TELL US
THAT U.S.-LED AIR STRIKES ARE
UNDERWAY CURRENTLY AS WE SPEAK
IN RESPONSE TO THE ATTACK ON THE
AIRBASE THAT LEFT TWO AMERICANS
AND ONE BRITISH SOLDIER DEAD
YESTERDAY.
THIS IS A RESPONSE TO THE 30
ROCKETS THAT WERE FIRED AT THE
BASE.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
AIR STRIKES TAKING PLACE AS WE
SPEAK IN MULTIPLE LOCATIONS
WHERE IRANIAN BACKED SHIITE
MILITIAS HAVE BOTH WAREHOUSES --
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO DISRUPT
THEIR COMMAND AND CONTROL.
IT WILL BE MULTIPLE LOCATIONS,
IT WILL BE A PROPORTIONAL
RESPONSE TO THE ATTACK ON THE
BASE.
HERE IS WHAT THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY SAID EARLIER TODAY.
AT THE PENTAGON TODAY, THE
DEFENSE SECRETARY WARNED THERE
WILL BE A RESPONSE TO AN ATTACK
THAT KILLED TWO AMERICANS AND
BRITISH SOLDIER IN IRAQ.
>> I HAVE SPOKEN TO THE
PRESIDENT, HE’S GIVEN ME THE
AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO.
>> AND IRANIAN BACKED MILITIA
LIKELY LAUNCHED THE ATTACK THAT
WOUNDED AN ADDITIONAL DOESN’T
COALITION TROOPS.
>> THE PROXY GROUP IS THE ONLY
GROUP KNOWN TO HAVE PREVIOUSLY
CONDUCTED AN INDIRECT FIRE
ATTACK OF THIS SCALE AGAINST
U.S. AND COALITION FORCES.
>> THE MILITIA LAUNCHED 30
ROCKETS AT THE CAMP LOCATED
70 MILES NORTH OF BAGHDAD.
AMONG THOSE KILLED, LANCE
CORPORAL BRODIE GILLEN, A
26-YEAR-OLD BRITISH ARMY MEDIC.
IT WAS THE LARGEST ATTACK ON
U.S. AND COALITION TROOPS SINCE
IRAN FIRED BALLISTIC MISSILES IN
EARLY JANUARY AFTER A U.S. DRONE
STRIKE KILLED IRAN’S MOST
POWERFUL GENERAL, QASEM
SOLEIMANI AT BAGHDAD’S AIRPORT.
YESTERDAY’S ATTACK COINCIDED
WITH WHAT WOULD’VE BEEN HIS 63RD
BIRTHDAY.
IRAQI FORCES HELP SECURE THIS
RIG WITH ROCKET LAUNCHING TUBES
A FEW MILES FROM THE BASE.
>> WE HAVE GOOD INDICATION BASED
ON FORENSICS WHERE IT WAS FIRED
FROM AND GROUPS THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> THE U.S. HAS TWO AIRCRAFT
CARRIERS IN THE REGION BUT WE
ARE TOLD THAT TOMAHAWK MISSILES
WILL NOT BE USED IN THE STRIKES
TONIGHT.
IF THESE WILL BE LIMITED TO
AIR STRIKES AS MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS ACROSS IRAQ AND THE
BORDER WITH SYRIA WORKGROUPS
LIKE ASTHMA LAW, ONE OF THE
IRANIAN BACKED SHIA MILITIAS
BELIEVED TO BE BEHIND THAT
ROCKET ATTACK ON TAJI, WHERE
THEY KEEP THOSE WEAPONS THAT
HAVE BEEN USED TO TERRORIZE
AMERICANS AND COALITION FORCES
AT THAT BASE IN IRAQ AND OTHER
BASES.
THIS IS DESIGNED TO BE A
PROPORTIONAL RESPONSE AND DETER